tu pars faire un test si vous êtes de
droite ou de gauche je vous aime
répondent par oui ou par non on va faire
le sait d'azur sa droite ou pas est ce
que est ce que vous trouvez lui que vous
payer trop d'impôts
oui non oui oui est-ce que vous pensez
que seuls les forts survivront et que
c'est très bien comme ça
non ça non est-ce que vous pensez que
les gens qui sont au chômage après tout
c'est de leur faute quoi non plus ça
c'est complètement idiot il ya un tas de
pneus en forme in anglais est ce que
vous pensez qu'il faille interdire la
consommation du cannabis
non non non non vous pas l'interdire car
on pensait contre la drogue arrête
toutes les drogues
si c'est pas pareil même le même le vin
alors mais c'est pas de la drogue
justifier la moitié un pétard tout luc
ferry est ce que vous êtes absolument
contre le mariage des homosexuels
oui oui est ce que vous êtes contre
l'adoption d'enfants par les couples
gays alors curieusement non avant d être
contre le mariage mais pour la volt
chiant oui en vérité vous avez le droit
je connais pas mal le problème pour
adopter moi même un enfant sans être
homosexuel mais attendez on a le droit
ou pas l'être ou la semence jugera
monsieur
quand il est si j'ose y ajoutant une
perche qui est tellement facile c'est
vrai voilà je
aujourd'hui vous avez le droit d'adopter
un enfant sans être marié ouais donc
vous pouvez parfaitement adopter un
enfant en étant au beau c'est là le sens
lyon donc ça n'a pas de sens d'interdits
est ce que vous pensez luc ferry qui a
pas assez de policiers dans les rues en
france
non là la différence entre un car de
fliquer une bonne lessive c'est que dans
la lessive ya un agent actif
c'est ça le premier pardon dans les
océans par devenir la quasi qu'une fois
que les bénévoles d'années par des vans
moi je vais jouer mon jeu c'est la mort
de mon commerce
mais non et puis des bo gars est ce que
vous êtes favorable à la suppression de
l'impôt sur la fortune
j'ai pas d'idée là dessus ouais si tu as
une idée mais tu ne te sens bien que tu
peux pas la dire et c'est en tout cas je
ne paye pas et je regrette donc il n'a
pas la rolls est ce que vous êtes
heureux luc ferry que le pauvre alain
juppé n'est pas été trop lourdement
condamnée par les juges
oui j'en suis plutôt content mais c'est
quelqu'un de très honnête donc c'est pas
un
jeanne lopis vous savez si j'avais
commencé la politique comme ça par
hasard quinze ans plus tôt j'aurais été
dans un système où par définition de
personnes ne pouvaient être à l'abri de
ça est vrai que c'est tout donc on a
assez nul système après peut-être qu'il
avait un petit retard à l'allumage
après l'assainissement du système quand
même les gens ne savent pas de quoi il
s'agit ça veut dire qu'il y avait des
types qui était à la mairie de paris qui
était payé par la mairie de paris alors
qu'il travaillait dans le parti
politique dont c'est pas bien non enfin
c'est pas non plus j'ai l'a pas tué une
vieille dame a fait pire que ce à quoi
on sait pas c'est pas et en plus il est
quand même condamné la fin il est pareil
quand même très cher à tandis qu'il a
vécu pendant toutes les années où il est
mis en examen et condamné après c'est
l'enfer vous pensez que les français
sont une population d'assistés vous non
est ce que vous êtes contre la
délivrance d'héroïne pour limiter le
trafic pour limiter le trafic ou voilà
je sais pas trop ce que ça veut dire
comment socialiste et dire qu'en moyenne
de l'héroïne aux gens pour éviter qu'ils
lâchent étaient des dealers aux enfants
pour les fidéliser sauna non lâche enfin
vous parliez tout à l'heure du cannabis
faut que ça notre problème héroïne donc
je crois que c'est vraiment une
saloperie oui vous êtes favorable aux
mesures contre les prostituées et leurs
clients
je suis pas enthousiaste de la chose
mais non je suis pas enfin comment dire
il faudrait distinguer deux choses il ya
le problème des raquettes sert d du fait
que vous avez des réseaux saissac vise à
nicolas sarkozy de prostituée qui
viennent de l'est donc force à se
prostituer et on leur dit si tu te
prostitue pas je vais flinguer ton père
ou ton frère
ça c'est ya rien de dégueulasse au monde
mais la évident quand vous êtes client
bon vous participez à un truc qui est
immonde mais ça n'a rien à voir avec le
plus vieux métier du monde qui est
peut-être pas bien mais qui à rien avant
avec ça c'est autre chose au moins je
suis pas là dessus pour confondre les
choses même si c'est pas ma tasse de thé
moi j'ai jamais été très bien mais ce
que vous dites c'est que vous n'êtes pas
pour les prostituées qui viennent de
l'est mais pour les autres ça va je suis
celle qui vient puis celles qui viennent
des joueurs intelligents cherche à
rompre et de bonne foi religieuse l
ouest
c'est moins grave d'accord vous trouvez
que jean pierre raffarin et bel homme
pour dire on vous répondait non allez on
va être non un nom et sympathie qui lui
est pas belle vous touchez sa bosse des
fois ça porte bonheur qu'est ce que
c'est que ça k o dia
je suis avait déjà touché la baisse de
jean-pierre raffarin ça porte bonheur il
est pas beau il est pas beau c'est pas
mal on brindeau non je crois que ce
serait une solution de rendre les
entreprises plus flexible en favorisant
les licenciements rapide
oui là aussi si je suis honnête oui je
pense que c'est le traitement social du
chômage ça n'a jamais été la solution
jouer normal comme emprisonne quelqu'un
qui sifflent la marseillaise bon nous et
me yves duteil moi j'ai joué un quart
d'heure de guitare avec puis elle était
ado c'est un pas vers quel démon le
combat de josé bové je trouve ça
ridicule c'est grotesque oui c'est un
boulet mais pas josé bové non il est
sympa moi j'aime bien moins maintenant
elle n'aime pas je les trouve intègre
moins courageux tomtom est là il est élu
président
là on a vu son vrai visage
qui transparaissait non mais pas de
haine mais c'est pas ma tasse de thé
pile côté comme ça et on dira pas qu'il
est courageux
non pas du tout
non non pas du tout parce que là tant il
rafle la mise à chaque fois c'est aller
les gens qui ont l'air courageux qui
rafle la mise en termes de médiatisation
à chaque fois ça m'exaspère un peu pire
j'avais des petits dérapages
comment dire en parallèle jean noël
voilà qui ne voit pas très clair je ne
me gêne pas du tout cette mouvance là
que je trouve assez politiquement
suspect ça commence par josé bové avec
les moustaches ans à la gauloise
sympathique et ça se termine par tariq
ramadan je vois la cour cycle et janvier
dites moi alors dernière question et
c'est la plus importante est ce que vous
porteriez des mocassins et des
chaussettes blanches je crois qu'il a un
mois qui a aucun problème donc avant le
score et 2 donc donc ils seraient plus
de gauche que de droite finalement je
comprends que chirac les virer
c'est plomb de la messieurs